the temporary injuries that is normal
from training you're going to get them
and so i had neck surgery that was a
blip on the right i don't even remember
how long it took what did i do during
that time i did other exercises i
figured other stuff i watched youtube
videos i figured out other moves you
know that's what i did what do you do
number one stay active right
you know move
do if you if you can't move your body at
all work your forearm strength
right squeeze a tennis ball you know if
you can't roll box if you can't box
lift if you can't lift
stretch and get that flexibility working
in some area that you're not flexible
whatever you're gonna do stay engaged
stay active and so the bottom line the
question was what does a man do
when there's quiet he takes advantage of
it right so take advantage of it get
smarter get better in other ways and
when the body comes back you'll you will
be better